i have found when i was first starting
out writing that when i started with a
theme like this is a movie about blank
that
it kind of became wooden
how does a writer find the central
thematic spark of their screenplay the
central thematic spark oh
yeah
that's like the magic that's part of the
magic that we were talking about i think
um
for me and this is just my experience is
theme comes like almost last
like i
it's not it's not a spark in the sense
of like a catalyst for an idea for me it
really is something that comes after
i've kind of
worked a lot and and basically thought
oh that's the theme and then no that's
not the theme and then that's the theme
and that's not the theme and suddenly
the theme is the thing for me that comes
last
it comes for me as a writer when i
have figured out who the characters are
what they want deeply what their fears
are
and as i see them
struggling to kind of get what they want
and
again it really happens for me toward
the end of the writing process in
revision
because i may think i have a theme
starting out and it's never that never
ends up what it's about because as i
explore and excavate my characters it it
it appears and it does feel like magic
because for me it's about like oh my god
this movie's really about this
i had no idea that it was about this and
i work with a lot of writers too who
think they know what their theme is
and um
it turns out that what they're writing
is not what they started out thinking
their movie was about and it's evolved
into something else and so that those
little things that they thought were
really important at the beginning of the
writing process end up falling away
in favor of whatever is now sort of
taking hold because of the character
development
in in the story
um so for me it's really it's part of
the magic and i don't i don't really
even know what my movie's about when i
when i start anymore i just i trust that
i will know
and i don't i don't know i have i have
found when i was first starting out
writing that when i started with a theme
like this is a movie about blank
that
it kind of became wooden
you know because i was basically just
writing to fulfill some prescriptive
kind of
tenet or something i don't know but when
i just
trust that i don't need to know my theme
i'll wait for it it will come to me
usually it does um sometimes it doesn't
and i have to have other people read it
to tell me what do you think this is
about because i just kind of get lost in
the weeds
um
yeah arthur miller i love this the way
he that we the way he worked with theme
um he had this little building outside
of his house that was like his writing
shed i'm sure it was really beautiful so
calling it a shed is probably wrong but
he would go out there and he obviously
was working on a typewriter right
because it was the 50s or whatever and
he would he would start writing his
plays
and
he said that in the writing process he
would suddenly realize what the theme
was
and it was usually when he was kind of
in the middle of writing his play and
then he would type up the theme and put
it above the typewriter and that guided
the rest of his writing
so he would find his theme in the middle
of the process of writing his plays
um and i'm sure there are some people
who have a theme at the beginning and
are able to kind of write to that
but it it to me it's kind of like
it's magical
like it's it's you need to like leave it
you need to let it come to you um
because i think it's not
even though a theme feels intellectual
like this movie is about this
i think theme theme is actually really
like from the heart it's a heart thing
not like a brain thing
um interesting yeah
so it sounds like okay because so much
of writing seems like there's these
rules and you're connecting the dots to
so much but with this and i'm sure this
is hard for writers to do you're letting
it go and you don't know that's right
that sounds like it's very troublesome
for writers so troublesome i mean and
and and obviously i'm not i'm not saying
like go crazy just write everything
because it's a balance like as a human
being you have a left brain you have a
right brain organizer holistic intuitive
you need both of them to write a great
script okay
and so you know part of it is magical
but but part of it is actually figuring
out like creating a map for yourself so
that you don't go out into the weeds now
i know people i know a lot of people who
don't have outlines that's great like if
you can do that if you can figure it out
and really let yourself be completely
free which to me is terrifying
i cannot be completely free because i
will just shut down it's too scary so i
make a road map for myself
um but then if i'm in there and it's
like oh this isn't working the way i
thought it would and this is boring like
where should this where should this be
going
you know and try to follow those things
so it's a balance of
of structure and also allowing for
creative discovery in the writing
process
you know so set your your sort of time
your date with yourself to sit down
whether it's longhand or at the
typewriter yeah have your little rituals
your offerings have your offerings and
then
start writing yeah and then hopefully
the thunder outside the window
brings what the theme is about or like
you said you you had other people look
at your work and say what they thought
the theme was yeah i mean when i get
really stuck and basically people come
to me when they're stuck right like
they've looked at their script and they
have taken it as far as they can
and they just need someone from the
outside to look at it we all do you know
and so i have people who look at my
stuff i have a friend um it's it's a
it's a girls group and um it's writers
it's producers um it's teachers it's
storytellers and you know we're friends
it's a social group but we also share
our materials with each other if we need
feedback and it has been so helpful i
just um i just wrote a book and i just
felt like i i don't know what to do with
this anymore and i gave it to them and
they were brutal
and they're extremely smart and i was
just like oh my god
this is gold and i was able to go back
in there see what i couldn't see right
because they're coming and so i think we
all as writers need those people like
who's our little circle
of um
who's our community of fellow writers
that we can go to and i'll read your
stuff and you read my stuff because yes
writing is a lonely sport but you can't
always be alone you actually do need
people
you know and that's the great thing
about working on a tv show because
you're in a room with lots of people now
there are issues that come out of that
right like personalities and all that
stuff and i'm sure you've talked to
people who are tv writers who have
stories to tell about writing rooms but
like the great thing about it is you're
in a room with other people
and you know i've worked as a story
consultant at pixar and one of the
things i absolutely loved is that like
i'm in a room with other people and
we're working together on this story
which is not normally the way feature
writers work
which is i'm a feature writer so it's it
was it was so fun to me to for me to be
in a room with other people um and so
you know i want to advise people like
find your group like who are your people
who can you share this experience with
and give encouragement to and notes to
and all that kind of stuff because
you can only take your project so far
alone you need other people
yeah and so with the talented mr ripley
what is the theme
gosh
the talented mr ripley is based on a
book by patricia highsmith
and patricia highsmith is one of my
favorite writers she's extremely dark
and it's all about twisted human
psychology
and
she wrote the price of salt which which
actually phyllis naj turned into the
amazing movie carol right so she wrote
about not just super dark things but but
other other things as well
but um the talented mr ripley honestly i
don't know what the theme is
it it it it
it doesn't i think the thing i love
about the movie and the book is that it
won't fit into our prescribed little
boxes of theme
you know or meaning because the main
character is this guy who's doing
everything a main character should never
do
and yet we're riveted by him
and so
we're able to kind of see
the humanity in the darkness in the dark
psychology and so i think
what i'm attracted to in her is that and
for me that's the theme it's like
wow
monsters are human too
and they are just like me in some ways
so that's why i love her stuff
um and her writing you know it's it's so
unique and so specific that you you you
can try
to kind of like box her in to like what
we understand as like this kind of movie
or this kind of book or this kind of
theme but like
she will not be boxed
which is what makes her great but she
faced a lot of criticism especially at
that time absolutely and you know her
politics were terrible i mean she really
was was in many ways not a great human
being
but as a writer like i have to admire
how
she just did what everyone said don't do
it don't do it and yet
and in doing that created these really
compelling characters that we should buy
all rights
not like and not feel empathy toward and
i think she pulls it off i'm not talking
about carol i'm talking about ripley
which is a completely different
character
um but yeah she just breaks the rules
which i love
you